hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live Cannabis soll legal werden das hat
das Bundeskabinett heute beschlossen
doch ganz so einfach ist es nicht das
muss nämlich jetzt erst noch geprüft
werden ob dieses Eckpunktepapier was der
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach heute
vorgelegt hat ob das auch internationale
Recht entspricht aber trotzdem die Frage
heute bei uns deshalb wie legal wird
Cannabis und wir können darüber
diskutieren mit verschiedenen Gästen und
vor allem können wir jetzt erstmal
schauen was wurde da denn heute
vorgelegt ich habe es angesprochen dass
sogenannte Eckpunktepapier
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach hat es
vorgestellt drei wichtige Punkte auf die
schauen wir jetzt schon mal gleich am
Anfang Erwerb und Besitz von 20 bis 30
Gramm Cannabis sollen straffrei werden
privater Eigenanbau wird erlaubt und der
Verkauf in lizensierten Fachgeschäften
soll dann möglich sein und der
Gesundheitsminister hat sich heute auch
geäußert und begründet seine
Entscheidung für diese neuen Regeln in
dem Papier folgen
wir wollen an der Entkriminalisierung
des Cannabiskonsums erwirken um damit
einen besseren Kinder und Jugendschutz
aber auch einen besseren
Gesundheitsschutz zu erreichen und somit
also den Problemen entgegenwirken die
wir feststellen bei der Bewertung der
derzeitigen Umgangsweise mit Cannabis
der Vertrieb und der Anbau sollen
staatlich kontrolliert werden das
bedeutet wir streben anders also der die
gesamte Menge die hier vertrieben und
auch konsumiert wird dass sie in
Deutschland produziert werden soll
über das Pro und Contra diskutieren wir
in dieser Sendung und außerdem im
zweiten Teil haben wir einen
Rechtswissenschaftler eingeladen
Professor Kai Amboss von der Uni
Göttingen und er wird uns erklären wer
realistisch eine schnelle Umsetzung
überhaupt ist und was haltet ihr von der
geplanten Legalisierung das könnt ihr
gerne natürlich jederzeit bei uns im
Chat und im Stream direkt kommentieren
und auch Fragen stellen oder auch per
Mail aber wir haben euch auch schon
vorher in unserem Community Tab gefragt
und unterschiedliche Meinungen bekommen
Haus & Jones bei Youtube schreibt Nein
zu Drogen a000 schön schreibt finde ich
gut Alkohol ist schließlich legal und
richtet wesentlich mehr an also
unterschiedliche Meinungen bei euch und
wie das unsere beiden Gäste sehen die
wir jetzt am Anfang der Sendung
eingeladen haben das erfahren wir jetzt
direkt und zwar ist bei uns Philine
edebauer sie ist von der Initiative my
brain my choice für die Legalisierung
und Martin Rüdiger er ist
therapeutischer Leiter von der von F 42
eine entwöhnungsklinik in
Berlin-Neukölln schön dass sie beide da
sind hallo hallo schönen Abend Frau
edbauer die erste Frage richtig direkt
mal an sie das Eckpunktepapier kam heute
raus sie finden das gut was finden sie
gut daran
also meiner Meinung nach ist es ein ganz
großer Wurf der hier gelungen ist und
wenn wir noch uns überlegen wo wir von
einem Jahr standen unglaublich dass so
ein
Eckpunktepapier überhaupt geschrieben
worden konnte also über die Ministerien
hinweg über die Parteien hinweg diese
Einigung zu haben das Gesundheitsschutz
und Verbraucherschutz und Jugendschutz
vorne stehen müssen bei der Gestaltung
von cannabis-politik
auch mit Referenzen dazu zu
Drogenpolitik insgesamt und damit nicht
nur
eine Vorlage zu liefern für eine
Legalisierung in Deutschland sondern die
ganze EU auch noch dort mit zu bemühen
jetzt 26 weitere Länder ja in die
Debatte mit rein zu nehmen sich damit zu
beschäftigen was der beste Weg ist für
eben diese Ziele und Herr Rüdiger als
Leiter in einer entwöhnungsklinik was
finden sie problematisch daran
[Musik]
ich muss vielleicht erstmal damit
anfangen ich finde das prinzipiell die
Straffreiheit finde ich eine super Sache
also das ist mir der wichtigere Punkt
als das problematische das ist was
worauf wir auch lange gewartet haben und
was für unsere Klientinnen und Klienten
total wichtige und hilfreiche Sache ist
problematisch finde ich allerdings das
Stichwort sowohl Jugendschutz
Kinderschutz Gesundheitsschutz
das sehe ich nicht ganz wie das auf
Basis dieses
Papiers vorangebracht wird und gehen wir
es mal zusammen durch gerne eben auch
mit ihren unterschiedlichen oder
vielleicht auch gemeinsamen Perspektiven
ein ganz wichtiger Punkt der steht da
gleich am Anfang und zwar der Erwerb und
Besitz von maximal 20 bis 30 Gramm heißt
es Genuss cannabis wird das Ganze
genannt soll eben straffrei sein
unabhängig vom konkreten THC-Gehalt die
Frage an Sie beide Frau vielleicht gerne
Ihre Antwort zuerst wie wie finden sie
das diesen Punkt
also es ist gut angesetzt damit kann man
leben sozusagen
idealerweise sollte es keine Grenze nach
oben brauchen aber jetzt erstmal um den
Start zu machen um den Übergang zu
machen von der bisherigen Gesetzgebung
halte ich das für vernünftig stimmen Sie
dazu keine Grenze nach oben Herr Rüdiger
prinzipiell ja ich glaube nicht dass das
einen großen Unterschied macht ob man
jetzt 30 Gramm oder 500 Gramm oder oder
ohne Grenze das nach oben
setzt ich finde die Menge zumindest
unter dem Stichwort Genuss Cannabis
finde ich das ein Stück weit musste ich
schmunzeln als ich das heute gelesen
habe das ist wie wenn man 5/6 Liter
Schnaps als Genuss genussschnaps
bezeichnet das finde ich ein bisschen
makaber stellen Sie sich auch an dem
Wort Frau
nee dass die Realität also wir müssen
noch viel mehr darüber sprechen über
Genuss eigentlich das hat in der Debatte
der letzten Jahre gar nicht
stattgefunden warum Cannabis eigentlich
auch gerne konsumiert wird man hat sich
sehr stark darauf fokussiert also nicht
nur in der politischen Debatte auch in
der öffentlichen Debatte hat sich sehr
stark auf die Schäden der Provision
konzentriert und wie Gesundheitsschutz
besser gelingen kann und Jugendschutz
und so weiter aber eigentlich gar nicht
darum gesprochen worum es geht nämlich
dass die meisten Menschen die mit
Cannabis Erfahrungen machen positive
Erfahrungen machen und das sehr gerne
mögen und Cannabis einen wichtigen Teil
von ihrem Leben spielt nur eben mit den
Problemen die halt durch die Projektion
bisher gekommen sind oder auch zum Tag
heute natürlich noch kommen bis das
Gesetz Realität ist
sie haben Genick Herr Rüdiger also da
gehen sie schon mit dass da der sich
eine Gemeinsamkeit ja total es gibt zwei
Personen es gibt jede Menge
Cannabiskonsumenten die das in der Menge
und in der Häufigkeit tun die nicht dazu
führt dass Leute in unseren Kliniken
landen und das ist der überwiegende Teil
insofern bin ich damit davor und ich bin
auch dementsprechend ja mit der
Straffreiheit davor
die Mengen die Umwelt über die wir da
sprechen das ist schon trotzdem eine
Hausnummer also
sagen wir mal ein
gelegenheitskonsument der kommt damit
mehrere Monate hin jetzt können wir
sprechen wir können darüber streiten wie
viel Gelegenheit ist aber wir haben auf
jeden Fall wir behandeln regelmäßig
Cannabis Konsumenten die konsumieren pro
Tag ein Gramm und damit kann man schon
wunderbar eine Abhängigkeit ausbilden
die die stabil und schwer zu behandeln
ist also die Menge 20 30 Gramm ich finde
das schon stattlich wie gesagt noch mal
ich finde das ein Stück weit irrelevant
wie weit man das jetzt aufweitet weiß
einfach schon eine hohe Menge ist ich
finde es nur aus sagen wir mal aus
symbolperspektive schwierig weil das
dann gelingt als während als wären 30
Gramm nicht viel oder als wäre das ein
vertretbaren vertretbare Menge
ich schaue mal unsere Kommentare es gab
schon einige ich fange an mit Ellen Hasi
schreibt bei Youtube warum soll Cannabis
legalisiert werden soll damit suggeriert
werden dass es nicht so gefährlich sein
soll oder wie ist es wie soll überwacht
überprüft werden wer wie viel Cannabis
mit sich führen bzw anbauen darf hat die
Polizei nicht schon genug zu tun was ist
ihre Antwort darauf Frau eidbauer wenn
sich jemand fragt warum soll das
überhaupt legalisiert werden
also weil das Verbot die letzten 50
Jahre nicht funktioniert hat und
nachweislich viel Schäden angerichtet
hat für Gesundheit für
eine Biografien wenn zum Beispiel der
Führerschein weggenommen wurde oder auch
eben Haftstrafen wenn man Cannabis
selbst angebaut hat
oder ja die Verlust von Job von
Ausbildungsplatz und so weiter das sind
alles Strafen oder Sanktionen oder von
der Schule geschmissen zu werden und so
weiter die einfach nicht gerechtfertigt
sind mit der Substanz oder mit der
Pflanze Cannabis das ist die
Rechtfertigung fehlt und deswegen ist es
einfach gebotene legale Regulierung zu
machen also Legalisierung vielleicht um
das auch zu klären heißt nicht dass es
dann wie Alkohol im Supermarkt verfügbar
sein wird das sieht man ja auch in dem
Eckpunktepapier dass es eben das nicht
ist sondern wirklich eine strenge
staatliche
kontrollpolitik ist die eingrenzt
wie wie der Verkauf der Gebrauch
auch bis zum gewissen Grad bis es in die
Privatsphäre hineingeht aber wie einfach
alle Faktoren die mit Cannabis
Zusammenhängen organisiert werden können
und dann kann man auch nachjustieren
entweder ein bisschen strenger machen
die eine Sache oder ein bisschen
lockerer wiederum gestalten und sich
immer wieder an den konkreten Zielen
orientieren die man ja hat was gelingen
soll also messbare Ziele also da möchte
ich auch kurz widersprechen es geht so
so was wie wir wollen keine falschen
Signale senden oder sowas sowas sollte
nicht mehr unser Maßstab sein sondern
wirklich messbare Ansprüche die man hat
eine gute Drogenpolitik oder
Cannabispolitik in dem Fall und darf ich
noch ein Wort zur Polizei weil das auch
kam dass die ja eh schon so viel zu tun
hat genau das ist das ist das was wir
beenden wollen also dass die Polizei
endlich rauskommt aus unseren
Privatleben dass wir nicht mehr Angst
haben müssen von der Hausdurchsuchung
oder für den Besitz von Cannabis den
Führerschein zu verlieren anders
behandelt zu werden weil man aufgrund
von
viel oder Äußerlichkeiten oder auch in
Zusammenhang mit Ration Profiling
angehalten wird und einfach anlasslos in
bestimmten sogenannten Gefahrengebieten
aufgehalten wird sondern alles Aspekte
die jetzt Alltag sind für viele Menschen
aber gleichzeitig für andere Menschen
die nicht mehr Cannabis zu tun haben
absolut unsichtbar sind und das ist
jetzt auch ein Prozess wo wir langsam
die Aufarbeitung kommen und das ist
unglaublich wichtig und wertvoll als die
Polizei soll weniger mit uns zu tun
haben
gehen wir noch mal einen wichtigen
Schritt in dem Eckpunktepapier durch sie
haben es angesprochen Herr Rüdiger auch
am Anfang der Jugendschutz Stichwort
Altersgrenze da heißt es der Verkauf in
lizenzierten Fachgeschäften der soll
erfolgen Zutritt erst ab 18 eventuell in
Apotheken also auch der Verkauf und
eventuell soll geprüft werden ob es für
unter 21-Jährige Käufer eine
thc-obergrenze geben soll reicht ihnen
das aus Herr Rüdiger nein also da ich
habe ein Stück weit die die Diskussion
in den Expertenkommissionen die davor
liefen mitbekommen und von Fachseite
wünschen wir uns eigentlich das ist
unrealistisch aber das ist fachlich
sinnvoll wäre würde man sagen 25 ist ein
alter was was was gut vertretbar wäre
das hat vor allem mit der hohen
psychoseneigung oder erhöhten
psychoseeigung bei jungen Menschen zu
tun die gerade bei Männern zwischen 18
und 25
am deutlich ist und und die schon durch
Cannabis anders als bei den meisten Auto
bei vielen anderen Wirkstoffen noch mal
deutlich hervor raufgesetzt wird also da
würden wir uns auf jeden Fall eine
höhere Grenze wünschen auch wenn das
total unrealistisch ist aber jetzt reine
Weg aus fachsicht erstmal
Frau sieht die sie für die Legalisierung
ja im einstehen kämpfen mit ihrer
Initiative sehen Sie diesen Punkt aber
ähnlich wie Herr Rüdiger oder stimmen
Sie dem nicht zu also ich stimme zu dass
es aus medizinischer Sicht wir auch
angedeutet wurde also wie du auch
angedeutet hast
sinnvoller wäre später anzufangen mit
dem Cannabiskonsum aber ist einfach
nicht Realität und im Sinne von
jugendschutz ist es nun mal
wünschenswerter wenn die Jugendlichen
die sowieso Cannabis rauchen also so wie
jetzt zehn Prozent
von einmal bis häufiger sondern das ist
auch breit und unterschiedlich wie
genutzt wie es genutzt wird wenn da
konstant eine niedrigere THC Zahl oder
eine Zusammensetzung genutzt werden kann
die dadurch auch weniger
Schadenspotenzial hat oder wenn safer
use Strategien angewandt werden wie zum
Beispiel vor allem nicht zusammen mit
Tabak zu rauchen was ja auch zu einer
Abhängigkeit oder
wahrscheinlich oder als naheliegend ist
das ist auch das beste Grund ist warum
es auch zu Abhängigkeiten kommt oder
warum bestimmt das Gefühl zusammen mit
den
cannabisgebrauch immer wieder gesucht
wird da ist ganz viel Potenzial auch mit
der legalen Regulierung da Antworten zu
finden klar die Abgabe ist ab Eltern und
vielleicht ja darüber wird jetzt
diskutiert so oder eben mit einer
Begrenzung der THC Zahl ab 21
aber trotzdem ist es immer noch besser
wenn junge Leute daran irgendwie kommen
als jetzt eben den Kontakt mit dem
kriminellen Markt zu haben Herr Rüdiger
ich habe gerade gesehen dass sie den
Kopf geschüttelt haben das damit die
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer nicht
gesehen warum das halte ich tatsächlich
für für für für einen Scheinargument
weil wir haben ein
durchschnittseinstiegsalter in
Deutschland mit Cannabiskonsum für den
Kanal bis Konsum mit ca 15 Jahren in der
Normalbevölkerung in den Gruppen die
später Probleme mit Cannabis entwickeln
haben wir im Schnitt die steigen mit 11
oder 12 ein das heißt die sind schon
sieben Jahre auf dem Markt bevor die
legal Cannabis erwerben können und die
werden nicht aufhören zu konsumieren
weil sie jetzt die Möglichkeit hätten ab
18 legal zu konsumieren sondern die
werden weiterhin konsumieren die werden
potenziell noch mehr Möglichkeiten haben
zu konsumieren weil es neben dem bisher
komplett illegalen Dealer vielleicht den
legalen älteren Bruder gibt der der
schon kaufen kann weil es die Leute aus
der 12 Klasse gibt die schlau sind und
das an die Siebtklässler dann mit einer
kleinen Gewinnspanne weiterverkaufen
also das sehe ich nicht inwiefern
überhaupt Cannabis Legalisierung zu
einer zum Jugendschutz beiträgt das ist
für mich absolut unerklärlich
es ist auch unseren Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauern wichtiges Anliegen xarexes
schrieb bei YouTube eine thc-grenze und
Jugendschutz fände ich schon wichtig
fragt sich gleichzeitig wie läuft es
denn genau mit dem Eigenanbau vielleicht
kommen wir zu diesem wichtigen Punkt
auch noch mal der war auch Teil dieses
Eckpunktepapiers das heißt jetzt hier
private Eigenanbau in begrenzten Umfang
sei erlaubt drei weibliche blühende
Pflanzen pro volljährige Person warum
macht das für sie Sinn da gerne Frau
eidbauer was sagen sie dazu also auch
grundsätzlich ich sehe nicht also jetzt
ideal gedacht warum es eine Begrenzung
geben sollte eine Pflanze anzubauen aber
da stehen wir jetzt nur an dieser
politischen Situation und auch generell
finde ich es vertretbar zu sagen okay
wir fangen jetzt erstmal mit einer eher
kleineren Menge an Pflanzen an bei der
bei dem ersten Entwurf der Regulierung
und dann kann man immer noch lockern
aber andererseits wiederum finde ich es
eigentlich dass man es würdigen sollte
die Menschen die die letzten Jahre durch
einen Eigenanbau ein sicheres Cannabis
auch hergestellt haben oder die diese
Fähigkeiten haben im Anbau vielleicht
auch 20 oder 100 Pflanzen anzubauen das
ist ja auch eine Fähigkeit die man haben
muss und dann eine gute Qualität zu
reduzieren also es wäre irgendwie schade
wenn das nicht auf die eine oder andere
Arten nicht doch noch mitgenommen werden
kann
sehen Sie das genauso Herr Rüdiger ich
muss sagen was das angeht dass es
ähnlich wie diese Gramm Anzahl ich bin
da relativ leidenschaftslos also ich
verstehe das für den Anbau dessen
relevanter Punkt ist ich verstehe auch
dass das für die
Strafverfolgungsbehörden relevanter
Punkt ist aber aus jetzt aus meiner
Profession heraus
sehe ich da keinen ist mir das eher ja
ist mir das nicht so wichtig sind also
gilt das auch jetzt dass sie sagen da
sind sie leidenschaftslos für den Punkt
da geht es jetzt darum das Produkte wie
Kapseln Sprays Tropfen zum Verkauf
zugelassen werden sogenannte addibles
also Keks oder Süßigkeiten mit Cannabis
aber zunächst nicht gilt es für sie auch
für diese Produkte
tatsächlich ein bisschen anders ich
glaube prinzipiell und das ist
eigentlich auch mein Haupt mein
Hauptschwierigkeit mit der Cannabis
Legalisierung nicht mit der
endkriminalisierung das muss ich noch
mal deutlich sagen an der Stelle wir
wissen einfach je mehr Leute etwas
konsumieren desto mehr bleiben darauf
hängen also für für uns geht es quasi um
große Zahlen je mehr Bundesbürger
Cannabis konsumieren desto mehr davon
werden abhängig das wird immer noch die
Minderheit sein aber die absolute Zahl
der abhängigen wird mehr und natürlich
je mehr ich verschiedene konsumen vom
anbiete desto
desto mehr finde ich einzelne Nutzer der
eine raucht vielleicht nicht gerne
findet es aber eine schöne Idee das zu
essen und so weiter und so weiter also
je mehr ich verschiedene
Darreichungsformen hat desto mehr
Publikum greife ich am Ende ab und desto
mehr Leute werden am Ende irgendwann bei
uns in den Kliniken landen was für uns
ich könnte jetzt sagen ja eigentlich
toll für uns aber das ist natürlich
nicht wir arbeiten ja daran dass es das
Leute sucht überwinden oder gar nicht
erst richtig werden statt unsere
Kliniken
Frau edbauer sie stimmen da nicht so es
ist richtig nee da will ich
widersprechen und zwar weil es diese
Behauptung dass je mehr Leute Cannabis
konsumieren desto mehr Leute Probleme
damit haben werden
von allem was ich weiß nicht stimmt und
zwar weil
man weil es weil es behaupten würde dass
eine Sucht kausal bei 10% der Menschen
wegen der dem Konsum das Substanz
entstehen würde und diese Theorie ist
wenn entweder verstaubt oder es ist auf
jeden Fall nichts was man aktuell
nachlesen kann die Ursachen von der
Sucht sind
die Ursachen für eine Sucht sind oder
eine Abhängigkeit sind vielfältig und
Sie müssen auch auf vielfältige Art
gelöst werden und individuell gelöst
werden aber das Potenzial ist doch da
das mit einer Legalisierung oder mit
einem Einstieg mattisierten oder einen
Umgang ohne Angst ohne Panik ohne Scham
und so weiter
mehrere Leute vielleicht konsumieren und
vielleicht auch ein Probierkonsum haben
ich finde das völlig in Ordnung jetzt
auch wenn manche Leute sagen ach jetzt
kann ich endlich mal Cannabis
ausprobieren ist völlig okay das soll
man dürfen und keine Angst davor haben
weil das Ziel ist doch das mehr Leute
einen unproblematischen Konsum erreichen
können durch Aufklärungskampagnen wie es
auch geschrieben ist im Eckpunkt für
Papier durch Darreichungsformen wie
vaporisieren statt Rauchen und so weiter
das kann man alles fördern und
unterstützen durch Preispolitik durch
Steuerpolitik und so weiter es gibt so
viele Möglichkeiten auch durch
Lizenzvergabe oder Werbeverbot und so so
viele Steuermöglichkeiten um die Schäden
zusammen mit Cannabiskonsum zu
reduzieren und nicht einfach davon
auszugehen es werden automatisch mehr
den Probierkonsum finden Sie den auch so
und problematisch wie Frau eight Bauer
Herr Rüdiger ich musste noch mal zurück
springen weil das tatsächlich dass das
stimmt schlichtweg nicht also abhängig
wird man von der Substanz deswegen ist
es nur substanzabhängigkeit man wird
nicht durch es gibt Faktoren die dazu
beitragen gibt es genetische Faktoren es
gibt sozial Sozialisationsfaktoren es
gibt
sich Dinge die wir jetzt im Detail
sprechen würden aber könnten aber im
grundsätzlich wird man von der Substanz
abhängig und Substanzen machen
unterschiedlich abhängig Heroin macht
abhängiger als Cannabis
cannabis macht abhängiger als Pilze
das hat was mir da Substanz zu tun und
nicht allein mit den
Sozialisationsfaktoren und wir wissen
ungefähr wenn wir auf einer bestimmten
Menge wenn eine bestimmte Menge von
Leuten das konsumiert können wir uns
ungefähr vorstellen wie viele von denen
ein problemkonsum entwickeln werden wie
gesagt in der großen Zahl nicht im
Einzelfall und das ist für uns eine ganz
einfache Rechnung je mehr Leute
konsumieren egal was desto mehr werden
Leute abhängig wenn wir in die USA
schauen wo in den letzten 10-15 Jahren
extrem viel Opioide konsumiert wurden
die viel mehr abhängig machen als als
Cannabis haben wir entsprechend
explodierende Zahlen von abhängigen
während wir natürlich in derselben Zeit
viel weniger explodierende Zahlen von
Cannabis haben weil es nicht so abhängig
macht aber es macht trotzdem auch
abhängig und am Ende ist immer die Zahl
der Nutzer
hatten Zusammenhang mit dem Zahl der
abhängig werdenden das ist nicht Leuten
war
und dementsprechend ich habe nichts
gegen Probierkonsum ich
kenne mehr als genug Drogenkonsumenten
ich habe selber genug
Erfahrung mit Probierkonsum alles gut
ich will nur einfach damit sagen wir
müssen uns bewusst sein je mehr Leute
probieren desto mehr Leute bleiben daran
hängen das ist ein Faktum offensichtlich
ein Punkt wo sie beide ganz
unterschiedlicher Meinung sind ich nehme
auch noch mal kurz unsere User mit rein
auch da gibt es unterschiedliche
Meinungen natürlich es gibt hier Franzi
K die schreibt ich bin 100% pro
Legalisierung allerdings finde ich dass
der Nichtraucherschutz viel stärker
berücksichtigt werden müsste vor allem
Gastronomie und Clubs sollten komplett
rauchfrei sein egal ob Cannabis glaube
ich da fehlten Wort oder nicht das ist
die Meinung von Franzi es ist gibt auch
viele die gerade im Punkto Jugendschutz
das war jetzt auch häufiger bei uns
schon Thema sich äußern moonshot
schreibt bei Youtube drogenkompetenz
bereits ab Grundschule ermitteln was ist
welche Substanz wie wirkt das was macht
das im Körper warum tun Menschen das
findet der die Userin wichtig und was
auch immer wieder häufiger kommt was ich
gelesen habe ist wie hier der Kommentar
Doppelmoral einsehen Alkohol gibt es ab
16 Kummer saufen ist legal aber jemanden
der einen geraucht hat nach drei Tagen
und nach drei Tagen wieder Auto fährt
dort sofort Führerscheinentzug sowieso
das Thema Führerschein das habe ich
jetzt häufiger in den Kommentaren
gelesen dass man dann eine Doppelmoral
sieht das sehen Sie beide auch so sehe
ich an ihrem nicken dann gehen wir noch
mal auf einen weiteren Punkt ein weil
wir sind ja jetzt überhaupt nicht die
ersten im Gegenteil wir sind ja die eher
spät als Land dass ich jetzt damit
auseinandersetze in den Niederlanden zum
Beispiel ist Kiffen schon lange
straffrei aber was da ja auch
interessant ist in den vergangenen 20
Jahren sind die Niederlande gleichzeitig
auch zum wichtigsten Umschlagsplatz von
harten Drogen in Europa geworden und
kritische Stimmen sagen eben da hat
diese Duldungspolitik damit hat es
begonnen Frau Gebauer
Entschuldigung
sehen Sie diese Gefahr nicht nee gar
nicht also die Niederlanden haben ja
auch keine legalen Handel entwickelt und
deswegen ist es jetzt nicht vergleichbar
mit dem was die Bundesregierung oder das
Kabinett jetzt vorgelegt hat das sind
zwei verschiedene Dinge das andere ist
dass die Niederlanden einen großen Hafen
haben und gleichzeitig gibt es eine
große Nachfrage in Europa das ist jetzt
nicht
also ist ein ernsthaftes Problem die
organisierte Kriminalität aber die lässt
sich nicht mit Drogenbekämpfung kleiner
machen das haben die letzten 50 Jahre
gezeigt sondern vielmehr damit naja mit
sehr vielen Unternehmungen die eher
wirtschaftspolitischer Natur sind oder
zum Beispiel jetzt konkret in der
cannabis-legerinisierung was jetzt noch
nicht Thema ist vom Eckpunktepapier ist
das oder eigentlich das Gegenteil im
Eckpunktepapier angedeutet wird
da wenn man sich abgrenzen vom illegalen
Handel und und dafür sorgen dass
zumindest die lizenznehmerinnen
eine in den letzten fünf Jahren keine
Vorstrafe haben
und eigentlich sollte genau das
Gegenteil getan werden also gezielt
versuchen Leute die im illegalen Markt
gehandelt haben die die Nachteile auch
erfahren an der unteren Spektrum und im
unteren Bereich der das illegalen
Handels die da auch jetzt nicht
irgendwie macht haben oder irgendwas
sondern die Gewalt auch Tag für Tag
erleben aber gleichzeitig nicht zur
Polizei gehen können dass man jetzt
schaut wie können wir die Schützen und
in legale Strukturen einbauen jetzt
jetzt wer genau dafür die Chance
dazu noch die spannende Frage von Jakob
schwarzer der gerne von Ihnen Herr
Rüdiger wissen möchte ob sie das wissen
gibt es in Ländern mit
dekriminalisierten legalen
Cannabiskonsum weniger Patienten
Patientinnen in den Kliniken die wegen
Cannabis Hilfe brauchen
das wäre schön wenn wir das wissen
könnten das ist tatsächlich die Frage
lässt sich meines Wissens nach nicht
wirklich beantworten nicht gut
beantworten weil die unterschiedlichen
Hilfesysteme in unterschiedlichen
Ländern die sind so
unvergleichbar miteinander
allein ab wann wir quasi ab wann
behandelt wird wir haben in Deutschland
ja ziemlich gutes vergleichsweise gutes
System was was die Gesundheitsvorsorge
angeht und
wir erreichen Leute
reichen viel mehr Leute als einen
anderen Ländern es gibt
ja ist das finde ich das finde ich
leider sehr schwierig da einen Vergleich
zu sehen weil auch die die Qualität der
Daten sich sehr unterscheidet von von
Land zu Land wenn wir das wüssten glaube
ich dann dann dann dann ließen sich für
für die Praxis ließen sich da einige
genauere
wie soll ich sagen
präventionspolitische Instrumente
ableiten
ganz zum Ende jetzt noch kurzes
schlussstatement von Ihnen beiden was
fehlt ihnen jetzt noch quasi was wäre
das was Sie sich jetzt noch wünschen
würden wie soll es weitergehen
also ich sehe das was was was was ich
mir wünschen würde dass es unrealistisch
ich hätte mir eine Entkriminalisierung
nach nach portugiesischen Modell
gewünscht ich glaube dass die dass die
Legalisierung in in Richtung geht die
die die ich problematisch finde aber an
der sich die so kommen wird wenn es denn
die EU Gesetzgebung zulässt ich würde
mir wünschen einfach ein bisschen mehr
Ehrlichkeit in der Debatte weil
tatsächlich die die die die Geschichte
mit Rückgang von Kriminalität durch
Schaffung eines legalen Marktes da gibt
es sehr sehr viele Daten die dagegen
sprechen und auch in der Sachlogik
läutet leuchtet mir das wenig ein
ich würde mir wünschen dass da einfach
ehrliche debattiert debattiert wird und
und nicht so viel mit Scheinargumenten
gearbeitet wird
für Sie das schlussstatement wie soll es
weitergehen was fehlt noch also ich
würde vorschlagen mehr Debatten
miteinander um dann zu klären was ein
Argument und Scheinargument ist und
diese Debatten weiterzuführen
und
das andere wäre eine vertiefende
Diskussion über soziale Gerechtigkeit
weil wir das hoffentlich in den nächsten
Monaten noch nachtragen können weil das
jetzt auch in dem Papier noch kein Thema
ist
als in der Auseinandersetzung damit was
damit wir überhaupt erstmal klar sagen
können was hat der stromverbot in den
letzten Jahrzehnten eigentlich konkret
angerichtet in welchen
Nachbarschaften mehr in welchem
Bundesländern mehr oder weniger
welche Bevölkerungsgruppen welche die
gender Perspektive sowohl im Handel als
auch unter den Usern und so was
eigentlich das für Deutschland bedeutet
hat und passieren darauf dann auch
dieses Wissen mitzunehmen wie eine
ordentliche Entschädigung und
Rehabilitation auch aussehen oder zum
Beispiel bei Führerschein weil das noch
mal kam
war es eigentlich der Umfang an Schaden
ist und was Menschen eigentlich für
Nachteile dann in welchem Umfang
erfahren haben so aus unserer
praktischen Arbeit und in Gesprächen
wissen ja so enorm viel aber das ist
noch gar nicht so eine öffentliche
Debatte
danke an sie beide danke an für den
Initiative my brain my choice und auch
an Martin Rüdiger der Leiter einer
entwöhnungsklinik in Berlin-Neukölln
auch danke aus unserer Community auch
insbesondere an Herrn Rüdiger habe ich
noch mal gelesen wirklich danke an den
suchtbetreuer ist keine einfache Rolle
bei so einem Thema also danke an sie
beide für heute Abend für diese
interessanten Perspektiven
danke für die Einladung
und wir haben jetzt noch mal Zeit ich
habe es am Anfang der Sendung
angesprochen natürlich auch noch mal
weiter in das Thema wie sieht es
eigentlich aus wie geht es rechtlich
weiter einzusteigen und da hilft es
natürlich auch mal zu schauen wie machen
es andere die Niederlande waren eben
schon kurz Thema bei uns und wir schauen
noch mal intensiver darauf wie machen
das andere Länder um uns herum in Sachen
Cannabis Legalisierung ein Beitrag von
Sven Regen
zum Klischee der Niederlande gehören
diese Bilder wie der Käse mal eben einen
Joint kaufen im Coffeeshop seit 1976
dulden die niederländischen Behörden den
Verkauf für den Eigenbedarf allerdings
ist der Großhandel weiterhin verboten
auch die Coffeeshops müssen sich also
auf dem Schwarzmarkt eindecken
man kann Cannabis kaufen und verkaufen
aber man darf es nicht produzieren das
hatte zur Folge dass für die Produktion
ein illegaler krimineller Markt
entstanden ist
die Folge die Niederlande sind zum
Umschlagplatz für Drogen auch harte
geworden und das Land ist fest im Griff
der Mafia ein Test in zehn Städten soll
das nun ändern dort soll das
cannabishaus staatlich kontrollierter
Zucht kommen vier Jahre soll das dauern
portugal hat im Jahr 2000 den
Eigenkonsum aller Drogen
entkriminalisiert dort spricht man nicht
mehr von
illegalem Handel sondern von der
Versorgung kranker Menschen
wir versuchen eine gute Beziehung zu
Drogenabhängigen aufzubauen so dass sie
uns auch sagen wie sie ihn wirklich geht
seit 2001 ist die Zahl der Drogentoten
im Land um 75% gesunken die USA sind ein
Cannabis Flickenteppich in 18 Staaten
ist der Konsum legal doch längst nicht
überall darf es verkauft werden in
Washington DC führt das dazu das Händler
Mark sein Cannabis verschenkt
wenn ihr bei mir etwas kauft gebe ich
das Cannabis gratis dazu wenn du eine
Mütze ein Hemd oder auch einfach nur ein
Sportbeutel kaufst dann hast du Anspruch
auf Cannabis in der Rohstoff kommt unter
anderem aus Kalifornien hier ist auch
der Anbau von Cannabis legal es gibt
sogar pflanzkurse für den absolviert
darf sich dann offiziell Cannabis
Sommelier nennen
und der Blick zu uns und wie es
weitergehen könnte das können wir jetzt
besprechen mit Prof Kai Amboss
Rechtswissenschaftler von der Uni
Göttingen schönen guten Abend
guten Abend
Herr Amboss Herr Lauterbach sagt
folgendes wir sind nun in einer Phase wo
wir prüfen ob die Grundlage die wir mit
dem Eckpunktepapier geschaffen haben
auch international tragfähig ist und
daher will er jetzt dieses Papier der
Europäischen Kommission zur Prüfung
vorlegen und damit quasi sehen ob das
eben geltendem und Völker und Europa
Recht entspricht was ist da ihre
Einschätzung Dritter eine positive
Bescheinigung bei rauskommen wie
schätzen Sie das ein
schwer zu sagen wir haben im Bereich des
europäischen Rechts also recht der
Europäische Union ein Rahmenbeschluss
und wir haben das schengender
durchführungsübereinkommen im Kern
verbieten diese Grundlagen den Handel
Cannabis mit allen Betäubungsmitteln und
deswegen kann Deutschland wenn es einen
eigenen Markt schafft ein legalen Markt
für Cannabis was ja eigentlich sinnvoll
ist wie wir auch eben von der Diskussion
gehört haben
nicht die Ausfuhr erlauben es muss quasi
sicherstellen dass Cannabis dann dieses
legale Cannabis Deutschland nicht
verlässt und
die
europarechtliche Frage ist noch zu
klären die ist eben noch nicht geklärt
insofern ist es sehr sinnvoll dass die
Europäische Kommission damit jetzt
befasst wird und zumindest mal eine
vorläufige Einschätzung geben kann weil
natürlich die Möglichkeit besteht dass
die Kommission oder auch ein
Mitgliedstaat wie zum Beispiel Polen
oder Frankreich die ja eine starke
repressive Politik vertreten dann ein
Vertragsverletzungsverfahren gegen
Deutschland einleiten
wander Wähler fragt sich dazu die Userin
bei Youtube kann eine Normalisierung von
Cannabis überhaupt an eu-
eigentlich nicht und deswegen ist es
wichtig
dass Deutschland die EU einbezieht in
diesem Prozess das ist ja ein Konsequenz
der schon monatelang anhaltenden
Beratungen der Bundesregierung die wir
wirklich sehr ergebnisoffen daran
gegangen ist als man den
Koalitionsvertrag geschrieben hat und
auch damals in der letzten
Legislaturperiode das
cannabiskontrollgesetz der Grünen hat
man sich noch nicht so klar gemacht das
ist sowohl europarechtlich wie
völkerrechtlich Probleme geben wird und
insoweit ist ist die Europäische Union
irgendwie mitzunehmen also man kann
jetzt hoffen dass die Kommission ein
Projekt was ja ganz stark auf Harmon
reduction die wir das nennen also
Verringerung von Schädigung also sehr
gesundheitspolitisch orientiert ist dass
sie den Ansatz versteht und es ist ja
auch ein Projekt das muss man ja betonen
in dem Action darüber wie wir das ja
deutlich es geht ja um absolute
Kontrolle im Rahmen dieses
legalen Cannabis Marktes eine viel
stärkere Kontrolle ist davor gesehen als
zum Beispiel beim Alkohol natürlich ist
die Frage wie man das in der Praxis
umsetzen kann wenn wir wissen eben auch
dass wir auf der EU-Ebene im
Europäischen Rat also wo er die
Regierungen
natürlich die cannabis-politik der EU
ändern könnten so eine Rechtsgrundlage
verändern können da keine Mehrheit haben
also wir haben in der EU bei den 27
Mitgliedsstaaten einen dicken Teppich
was Cannabis angeht sie haben jetzt im
Bericht in Niederlande genannt und
Portugal die sind ja auch
unterschiedlich aber sie haben eben auch
Länder die ganz stark auf die
Kriminalisierung setzen das heißt sie
werden keinen Konsens im Rat bekommen
genau sie haben die Niederlande
angesprochen darüber haben wir auch im
Beitrag viel erfahren da ist es die
Frage was ist denn der faktische
Unterschied zwischen der Straffreiheit
wie wir das in den Niederlanden eben
haben und dann der Legalisierung von
bestimmten Mengen
so in der Niederlanden gibt es
eigentlich keine Straffreiheit das ist
immer so ein Missverständnis dass
niederländische
drogengesetzt kriminalisiert den Besitz
den Erwerb und so weiter von Cannabis
insoweit genauso wie das deutsche
Betäubungsmittelgesetz aber die
Niederländer haben über die
Strafverfolgungsbehörden konkret die
Staatsanwaltschaft ein Ermessen die
niederländische Staatsanwaltschaft hat
er messen die deutsche
Staatsanwaltschaft hat
verfolgungspflicht wir nennen das
Legalitätsprinzip und insofern ist
sozusagen diese Duldungspolitik eine von
der Staatsanwaltschaft praktizierte
Politik manchmal wird dann auch was
beschlagnahmen aber an sich ist es ist
es Strafbar materiell rechtlich in den
Niederlanden anders in Portugal da ist
es tatsächlich so dass man
endkriminalisiert hat also man hat
die die dem Besitz von der Strafbarkeit
herausgenommen und das als
verwaltungsunrecht wie wir das nennen
als eine Ordnungswidrigkeit also wie
wenn sie quasi jetzt zu schnell fahren
und Bußgeld bekommen hat es auf diese
Stufe gehoben es ist also weiter
verboten es ist aber entkriminalisiert
und weitergeht ist eben ein
legalisierungsmodell dass man sagt wir
verbieten es auch nicht sondern wir
erlauben diesen Konsum und da gibt es
natürlich auch noch mal Abstufungen hier
sagen ja also die Bundesregierung sagt
ja auch da es ist
ein Beispiel im Supermarkt sondern es
läuft dann über lizenzierte Geschäfte
oder Apotheken mit einem sehr sehr
diffizilen Kontrollsystem und das müsste
man natürlich dann auch mal in dem
Gesetzentwurf sehen da steckt der Teufel
wirklich im Detail
aber geht Deutschland also jetzt quasi
mit diesem Eckpunktepapier tatsächlich
weiter als andere Länder
es geht weiter als die gesamten
Mitgliedsstaaten der Europäischen Union
Portugal ist zum Beispiel ja sehr gelobt
worden auch in hohem Kontrollrat der
Vereinten Nationen aber eben deshalb
weil es nicht legalisiert hat sondern
endkriminalisiert und das über eine Art
Ordnungswidrigkeit wie wir das nennen
abgehandelt hat aber in der Europäischen
Union gibt es kein Land
Luxemburg hat das mal versucht hat aber
dann zurückgerudert da ist gerade
ausgesetzt worden gibt es kein Land was
das versucht was die Koalition versuchen
will und insofern hat Deutschland
natürlich eine Pionierrolle eine
Vorreiterrolle und ich bin auch der
Meinung dass wir diese Diskussion führen
müssen und Deutschland ist immerhin der
wichtigste Staat in der Europäischen
Union in Deutschland also hier eine
Diskussion nicht in die Wege leiden kann
welcher Staat soll es dann erreichen
außerhalb der Europäischen Union haben
wir allerdings Staaten sie haben wir
eben die USA genannt da wäre zum
Beispiel Kalifornien zu werden sie haben
Kanada nicht genannt aber Kanada wäre
auch ein Staat hier so weit geht und
etwa hochweit
wir haben mehrere Fragen bei uns hier im
Stream und eine die öfter kam war die
Entkriminalisierung kann die denn schon
früher greifen für die Selbstversorgung
also die das ist eine Forderung die in
der Wissenschaft erhoben wurde und auch
von Seiten der Justiz teilweise aber das
hat ja Lauterbach der heute abgelehnt er
nennt das diese vorweggenommen oder
antizipierte
Entkriminalisierung also letztendlich
ist die Frage ob man wenn ein
Gesetzgebungsvorhaben im Raum steht
jetzt sozusagen schon
Ermittlungsverfahren die man hat gegen
bestimmte Personen einstellen also
sozusagen vorweggenommene Wirkung das
Gegenargument ist eben na ja der die
Gesetzeslage ist eben jetzt noch wie sie
ist wir haben ja noch gar kein Gesetz
wir sind ja immer noch in so einer vor
Diskussion und wieso sollte ich dann als
Staat schon vorweggenommen
entkriminalisieren der Gesetzgeber muss
zunächst mal dieses Gesetz verabschieden
und dann kann man entkriminalisieren
beziehungsweise legalisieren dann kann
man es eben umsetzen
jetzt wenn wir zum Schluss noch mal auf
den zeitlichen Horizont blicken auch
hier zitiere ich noch mal den
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach sagte die
Erstellung dieser Eckpunkte das war
keine Kleinigkeit und in der Komplexität
geht das über das hinaus was durch einen
schönen sudoku-abend abgerufen wird und
sagt jetzt eben er könnte sich
vorstellen dass wenn alles gut läuft die
Legalität 2024 erreicht ist also das
dauert ja tatsächlich noch eine Weile
sehen Sie das realistisch 2024 was
glauben Sie wo stehen wir am Ende
das ist sehr schwer zu sagen also dieser
notifikationsprozess also dieser
befassungsprozess in der Kommission das
kann schon bis Mitte 2023 geklärt sein
also die Kommission kann sich geäußert
haben aber wir müssen ja auch den
parallelen Prozess bei den
völkerrechtlichen Organen der
bürgerrechtlichen Konvention das sind ja
drei Konventionen also insbesondere im
zuchtstoffkontrollrat die muss man ja
auch in die Wege leiten da muss man sich
überlegen wie die reagieren werden und
dann haben wir noch den innerstaatlichen
Prozess wir haben ja wahrscheinlich hier
eine Beteiligung des Bundesrates es wird
ja in dem Eckpunktepapier auch etwa
bezüglich der Zugangsbeschränkungen zu
den lizenzierten Geschäften gesagt die
Länder können das
noch mal selbstständig anders regeln
oder sozusagen die Beschränkungen da
verschärfen das ist so ein bisschen wie
die
corona-gesetzgebung und daraus ergibt
sich schon für mich dass dieses Gesetz
ein offensichtlich dieses Gesetz ist das
also der Bundesrat wird zustimmen müssen
und das ist ja noch gar nicht ausgemacht
was dann am Ende sozusagen rauskommt da
kann vielleicht der
Vermittlungsausschuss eingesetzt werden
also das ist schon noch ein langwieriger
Prozess und dieses
Beratungsverfahren läuft auch noch
weiter also es gibt weitere
beratungsveranstaltungen die die
Bundesregierung macht was auch gut ist
auch internationale Veranstaltung
insofern sind wir immer noch in einem
dynamischen Prozess der Verhandlung und
der
Vorbereitung der Gesetzgebung ein
dynamischer Prozess der noch eine Weile
dauern kann vielen Dank für die Analyse
Prof Kai Amboss von der Uni Göttingen
danke gerne schönen Abend noch ebenso
und euch auch einen schönen Abend ihr
habt gemerkt das Thema das bleibt uns ja
noch eine Weile erhalten auch jetzt
gerade mit diesen Aussichten die wir
eben gehört haben also wir bleiben dran
und ihr seid hoffentlich wieder dann
dabei bis dahin vielen Dank und tschüss